sure hope you have binged all the
previous videos prior to this because
otherwise you are not going to be able
to follow this
[Music]
hey there folks this time we're going to
talk about
storytelling specifically storytelling
in television specifically what are
often thought of as two
extreme opposites in terms of
ways that storytelling is done in
narrative in television episodic
and serialized
now um
i as is usually my want it's something
fairly recent that has got me thinking
about this and wanting to lay things out
in specifics and that is the most recent
season of doctor who aka doctor who flux
now i'm going to try
we'll see what happens i'm going to try
and not dwell too much on doctors
specifically because i don't mean for
this to be a doctor who video however
the reason i need to talk about this is
because when the first episode of that
series aired and i did not particularly
like it
a very common and eventually especially
for how often it was deployed
infuriating thing that would happen in
my comments was somebody
saying that you can't complain about
this it's serialized you don't know
where it's going
you have to wait till it's done
which is
ridiculous
because serialized storytelling still
has to start off on good footing and
engage you and make you want to know
what's going on it can't just lay out a
bunch of mysteries and be like okay
you're going to keep you're going to
keep watching and following us now
because
maybe i won't if you suck at it but you
know
we're getting ahead of ourselves
at its most basic episodic television
deals with completely self-contained
stories in any given episode serialized
stories every episode is part of a
greater story so your typical sitcom is
going to be episodic every episode ends
with the same status quo with which it
began any changes that happen are
incredibly gradual and basically they're
just character drift over time as
opposed to deliberately plotted
storytelling serialization would be
something like game of thrones which
ended badly but was very much
presented in a way that every episode
and every part of it was just a new
chapter in this greater story
now the common narrative is that
serialized storytelling is relatively
new to television because we kind of
really started seeing it ramp up with
things like the sopranos the wire
breaking bad and while with shows like
that certain episodes might be more
contained than others
these are not shows that are designed
with the intention that you could just
jump in on any given episode and more or
less pick up what's going on everything
is built on explicit knowledge of what
came before and if you don't have it
you're not going to follow what's
happening whereas episodic especially in
terms of television the general design
philosophy of an episodic show is
somebody can catch any given episode and
while there may be references or
characters they don't know they're going
to be able to pick up and follow at the
very least the story that's going on
within this episode it's not going to
feel like something incomplete and it's
not going to feel like something that
they couldn't understand because they
don't have all the context it is
designed to stand on its own
and there seems to be a general sense
lately that serialized is
somehow better
it's a somehow
higher form of art
which
is kind of funny
if you realize that serialization used
to be viewed in the opposite way because
while serialization to prime time and
large budget television that is
relatively new i mean let's be honest
big budget television is kind of a
newish thing anyways television was
always seen as the cheap medium for the
most part
so
the thing is that
it's more recent in that more high-end
big budget looks real good prestige
television but you know where serialized
storytelling existed for
ever
soap operas
daytime television
now
those would still pick up new viewers
over time but part of that was based off
the fact that they had decades worth of
history that no one was going to get
caught up on anyways but everything was
still built on what came before so you
came in not knowing what's going on
originally but then you pick up and you
move forward from there was how it would
attain new viewers and the reason it was
done in daytime television as opposed to
prime time television for a very long
time was because of the presumption of
an old
model of a family dynamic
the presumption
that the woman of the house the wife the
mother
is home during the day and is
effectively a captive audience
prime time while it generally does get
higher ratings because kids are home
from school
fathers are home from work like i'm
dealing with the old uh nuclear family
model here this is all nonsense i know
that just roll with me
they're home and so now more people are
going to be driving the viewing and more
households will tune into things in
prime time whereas generally the viewing
numbers are going to be a little bit
lower during the day but that daytime
audience is reliable and you can count
on to keep coming back and so you would
provide them with stories that aren't
just retreads of the same tropes aren't
just the same setup and an and
a new plot
technically the way something like a
procedural like law and order would do
is like no we are going to move things
forward every day so you come back every
day
so serialization is not somehow
inherently more prestigious or grander
it's in a lot of ways harder to pull off
though
because the thing about episodic truly
episodic there's also a lot of gray area
in the transition we'll get there truly
episodic television
really it just it ends the same way it
starts whatever happens in the middle
it's fun it's ridiculous or it's even
dramatic but we end where we started
whether it's because it's a sitcom where
the wacky shenanigans are over or
whether it's because it's a police
procedural where that's the end of that
case we'll move on to the next case and
there are advantages and disadvantages
as far as storytelling goes with
episodic or serialized episodic does
allow it to be much more accessible to
anyone at any point
you can basically just jump in whenever
get a complete experience maybe not even
feel the need to come back but you got a
complete viewing experience in that one
episode they can be comforting in that
way because they become almost reliable
that does also tend them to be very
formulaic and often repetitive although
depending on the nature of the audience
the repetition might even be part of the
comfort of them now serialized when done
well has the potential to tell a much
bigger grander story
certainly than you get from episodic
television arguably even more so than
you would get from movies because you
can do something over a longer period of
time bring in more characters spend more
time more hours
telling this story
however there's a number of uh potential
downsides to surrealization the most
common one being getting canceled before
you finish
that's actually uh kind of a big one
like
we talk about
the shows like i mentioned but for every
one of them there are
dozens every year of shows that want to
be the next sopranos they want to be the
next game of thrones or
i mean more likely than not
what they really want to be
is the next lost
because that's another thing that
serialization
can do
although rarely pays off well which is
serialization can
spin a mystery over a much longer period
of time
an episodic mystery show
you're going to know who did it by the
end of the episode you're going to know
what's going on even something more
surreal like the twilight zone or the
outer limits by the time the hour is
over you'll know what's going on
lost captured a lot of people's
imaginations by hanging them on the edge
of their seats and
wanting to know what's going on season
after season after season and
almost nobody was happy with that last
season that's not saying nobody was my
partner liz actually really liked the
last episode but
it shows some of the inherent problems
with serialization which is
as much as we love the idea
and the image of creators who have a
carefully
meticulous plan as to exactly what
they're going to do and what everything
means they don't actually do that
not if they're smart that's what a
very dumb
tv writer would do because you need to
have it be more nebulous you don't know
if you will lose actors if they will
quit the show ask for too much money
have to be fired pass away you don't
know if the
network that you're airing it on is
suddenly going to ask for more seasons
than you originally planned hello
supernatural which is mostly episodic
but it does ride the line a little bit
there was a plan for that show for about
five years but it went on for 15.
no you all these things there's so many
unknowns
and nobody who knows what they're doing
in television has a rigidly locked in
plan for a serialized story you have to
keep it looser because it has to be
maneuverable and adaptable and that's
part of the magic trick
of serialization
now the big exception to that is of
course game of thrones which was fine
until they ran out of book and then it
got to that last season and oh
dang
which also illustrates one of the risks
of serialization
serialized stories are dependent on
their endings
in a way that episodic
isn't and won't ever be
because look
no matter what you thought
about the final episode of seinfeld at
the time that it aired most people
didn't like it that much at best they
thought it was a weak way to end
that doesn't impact your enjoyment of
the rest of the show because the
episodes are all self-contained knowing
that there is a
final episode later on down the line
well just don't watch it who cares
game of thrones you can't really do that
because
every episode every season was building
onward
to
that horribly botched final season
and the things that came before wow very
good television in their own right
don't really stand alone
[Music]
and a bad ending can sour the entire
experience and that is a risk
with serialized storytelling now i
mentioned that there's actually a lot
more gray area than people tend to think
about
one of the things that started really
coming about in the 90s and early 2000s
with your babylon fives your buffy the
vampire slayers your star trek deep
space nines and to a certain extent your
ex files
were shows that had an episodic format
and template
but were doing
overarching stories that were more than
just character drift i used that term
earlier character drift is just the
characters changing a bit over time and
so that if you look at an episode of
even like a sitcom from the first season
and then the fifth season there will be
notable differences not because of any
major upheaval but because of little
things that changed over a long a period
of time but again that's just kind of
what happens if you're not going to
deliberately try and never have anything
change i mean the most common example of
that is whenever you're dealing with a
family sitcom kids grow up
but you know characters get new jobs
they get in new relationships etc that's
not what i'm talking about
with some of the shows that i mentioned
they were more or less episodic for the
most part
with most individual episodes dealing
with a specific situation that is going
to be more or less resolved by the end
of that episode but also building
towards and keeping moving actively a
grander story in the background whether
it be a story of political and social
upheaval
with something like ds9 or babylon 5
whether it be the moving forward of
conspiracy like in x-files or whether it
be the big bad moving their plan forward
towards the finale of the show for buffy
the vampire slayer
there's a lot of middle ground to be
written
and it is frustrating to me that people
tend to talk about serialized or
episodic in pretty stark and absolutist
terms as if an episodic show always
looks like law and order and a
serialized show always looks like either
lost or game of thrones depending on how
much mystery they're working off of
neither of those is accurate
now to circle back
onto
the new season of doctor who just for a
little bit
what was really frustrating for me
was seeing people use the idea that this
series is serialized this current one
as a blanket defense
for
any issue especially the ones that i had
because i accused that first episode of
being overstuffed and lacking in a clear
central story
which
in my mind is just bad storytelling and
i lost count of how many people in my
comments told me well no you can't say
that that's not a fair criticism because
it's serialized you're not supposed to
know everything it's not that i expect
to know everything
it's that all that stuff crammed in
there
within one episode
nothing being resolved and nothing being
the clear primary thing that we're meant
to be focusing on and no don't tell me
that well we focus on the flux the flux
is this vague nebulous threat that is
really undefined by the end of that
first episode and it's really lacking
in a clear purpose and main thing if you
want to compare it to something like
lost that first episode while it piles
on a crap ton of stuff that you're like
what is going on there's a clear central
thing
happening plane crashed
survivors trying to gather and be
together and safe there was a main core
central thing and all this other
weirdness going on around it that first
episode of dark drew flux did not have a
main core central thing and even if we
get to the final episode of this series
and it pays off every single plot thread
that will still be a bad first episode
for a serialized story because if i was
not already invested in doctor who it's
not the kind of serialized setup that
would have made me come in and keep
watching
because like i said
there is a long
long
long
list
of shows
that have gone in
and leaned in heavily
on the mystery idea and the idea of come
back and watch this story unfold we'll
tell you the answers
but if you can't give us strong
characters and a core reason to care
just finding out the answers isn't
enough
we have to be invested in what those
answers will mean
because otherwise it's trivial we might
as well read a wikipedia page
and that's the thing serialization
is kind of a high risk high reward way
to go
it if nailed and i mean nailed it can
capture
the zeitgeist and the audience attention
in a way that episodic
really can't not anymore
and
sometimes that's a reason to try for it
but when serialization fails
it fails hard
especially because it's hard to adjust
a serialized story i talked about them
having to be malleable enough to deal
with some kind of changes but you can't
do a major overhaul
on a serialized story without it being
traumatic to the narrative and the
characters because you designed it to
move forward and tell this story but if
something's not working our fans aren't
responding or audience just isn't taking
to it
trying to pivot
something with that clear a destination
or that clear direction
doesn't really work episodic it's a lot
easier okay let's shake it up just
change the format we'll go in another
direction we're not as
firmly rooted in
forcing ourselves in this one direction
we can pivot and go other ways if we
need to i mean as a random example the
sitcom family matters steve urkel was
supposed to be a one-off character in
one episode
and he ended up taking over the whole
damn show
and that's the kind of thing that
wouldn't happen in serialization
not to say that i want more steve urkels
in pop culture i don't
but i'm just saying that having that
malleability and that freedom always
makes episodic a little bit of a
safer way to go
lower risk
but that doesn't make it
lazier that doesn't make it lesser
good episodic television
is still worth seeing and it's worth
pointing out that at this point
very few things are the pure episodic
that things like
law and order or you know 90s 80s and
earlier style sitcoms were
they're still
mostly the hybrids especially if they're
anything even close to dramatic but at
this point
even sitcoms have started getting
overarching stories
so
serialization
can be amazing when it works
but it can go badly and it depends on
sticking the landing so much
just please don't use it as a blanket
defense for the way something's
structured well it's serialized or this
presumption that oh if it's serialized
that'll be better not
necessarily
so yeah i did end up keep circling back
to the doctor who think yeah that's
stuck in my crawl a little bit you know
what we'll wrap it up there though
serialized episodic do you have an
inherent favorite or what are your
favorite
extremely episodic or extremely
serialized shows
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
like share subscribe i got a patreon
that's how i pay my bills every little
bit is able to help me out immensely but
even if you can't
don't worry too much about it
because at the end of the day
you are the council i'm just running the
meeting so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey if you're sticking around through
the credits might as well hear some
names read out my patreon helps support
this and in particular i want to thank
raven mcbain bookworm mj tracy scrabbit
vincent paul bartolucci kailyn schwartz
edelen robin moore ross schultz shayla
gourlay want to hear me mispronounce
your name check out the rewards on the
patreon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]